We decided to approach this problem by just taking apart
the system in a test tube and see if we can put it together again,
and find out what were the critical components that were needed to get membrane
organelles to move in this test tube environment.
So what we did know were that microtubules were a key roadway for
this transport of membrane organelles.
So we knew how to prepare them from purified tubulin and we can
make very pure microtubule tracks.
The next thing that we needed to get was the cargo that was moving inside the axon.
These are membrane organelles; these we had to get from the squid giant
axon. A third critical component was the fuel--
adenosine triphosphate. That we knew was essential,
and that we could fortunately buy from a chemical company.
Most people,
including us,
thought that the motors would be tightly bound to the cargo,
so the experiment was to make all these components, put them back together
in this test tube environment,
put it under a microscope and see if we could see the movement of these membrane
organelles occurring in this complete test tube in vitro
condition,
just as if it was occurring inside of the squid giant axon itself.
This experiment was originally done in 1984 at an institute called the
Marine Biological Laboratory at Woods Hole,
Massachusetts.
The day starts, actually,
with fishermen going to sea and collecting squid and bring them back to us.
At that point,
we have the animals in hand and we can begin our preparation.
So for making the tubulin,
we had already protocols that were developed for making tubulin
from bovine brain,
and we wanted to adapt it to the closest thing that a squid had to a brain,
which is something called the optic lobe.
So our strategy was to use the squid optic lobe as the
biochemical source for squid tubulin, which we could then use to make
microtubules.
This part here is called the squid optic lobe,
and I'm going to start by removing the squid optic lobe right
there,
which we'll use for our biochemical preparation of tubulin.
From the squid,
we wanted to then collect the giant axon.
So this is the inside of the squid and now we're going to do the dissection of a
squid giant axon.
And this is the cartilaginous backbone of the
squid,
which is called the pen.
And you can see it looks like an old fashioned writing pen.
I can also use this to point to different parts.
So all of these lines that you see here are
axons.
They're all coming from this body of neurons right here.
So all of these are innervating the muscle.
And the biggest of these axons is the squid giant axon and it lies right
along the pen, right in the middle here.
So this is the axon that we're going to have to dissect out.
There's one on either side here.
So the next step is to dissect out that axon.
We had to very carefully get the giant axon,
tie it off,
remove it from the squid.
Here we are removing the giant axon and
also a protective sheath that is
covering it. There,
now we've got, inside of here, our giant axon, and
we'll have to clean it up later,
but that is starting prep for removing it from the squid.
So this is the squid giant axon right here.
What I am doing is cleaning all of that sheath and kind
of material that is covering the squid giant axon.
Then we needed to get the inside of the squid axon out.
That can be done fairly easily just by cutting it.
And then you can squeeze out the inside of the giant axon, more or less like
rolling out toothpaste from a tube.
And that rolled out axoplasm,
which is the inside of the squid axon,
was the starting point for our preparation.
From there,
we had to then prepare the cargos, the membrane organelles, and separate them
from the soluble protein fraction.
So inside a cell,
many proteins are bound to particular compartments--
a mitochondria, a nucleus,
a membrane organelle--
but there are also many proteins that are freely moving
around in the cytoplasm, they're unattached to anything,
and these are often called cytoplasmic proteins.
And when you break open the cell,
they end up being in what's called a soluble protein fraction.
So to do this,
we took the axoplasm,
put it in a buffer,
which is a biochemical solution,
disrupt the axon with a Pipetman,
and then we place that disrupted axoplasm
on something called a sucrose gradient. A sucrose gradient is a biochemical
technique that can be used to separate, or another word is
fractionate, different components inside of a cell.
Imagine taking sucrose, sugar,
which may be in your kitchen and dissolving it in water,
but now keep adding more and more sucrose.
Eventually,
it gets very viscous and thick.
That was the general solution that we used in this
sucrose gradient, a very thick,
viscous solution of sucrose.
In fact,
we made different percentages of sucrose:
a very dense layer at the bottom and progressively lower density
layers higher up in this tube.
We then put the axoplasmamic fraction on top of the sucrose gradient
and then put it in a centrifuge which, would spin that tube around
amazingly fast.
So this is the centrifuge,
and this is the rotor that
is used for spinning the sample.
So here I'm going to put our sample in the bucket here,
and it's very important that you have a counterweight.
In fact,
these two buckets have to be very carefully weighed so the rotor doesn't
become imbalanced.
I'm going to put it now inside the centrifuge.
And now we're ready to start centrifuging the sample.
So I'll hit the start button here.
And you can see the rotor now starting to spin.
What happens then,
is all the material in that sample start
moving down the tube through the sucrose gradient.
If you're a very large object,
you travel down that tube faster and that causes the membrane
organelles to form,
collect there, and form a little band between that interface
between the low and the high density sucrose.
And this allows us to get a very crisp band of those
membrane organelles that we could remove with a pipette
and then use in our experiments.
But one thing you learn in biochemistry is to keep all of your fractions when you do an
experiment,
whether you think you may need them or not.
In fact,
we kept other parts of that sucrose gradient, including one
fraction which was at the very top of the sucrose gradient which was the
soluble protein fractions.
And again,
we just put that aside and also placed it in the ice bucket, just in case we
needed it later.